then also later on in the week.
We'll get you those details
tomorrow and Wednesday.
Now we're going to turn our
attention to Russia.
In the 2nd half the back half
of this hour. But I want to
start.
And our response to covid and
the backlash that is finally
happening against over the top
on scientific safety
Barry Weiss is a former New
York Times. Editor. She
famously left that newspaper in
a blaze of glory wrote a
scathing resignation letter.
And she's gone independent you
gotta substack I think she's
really interesting. She's left
of center. She's not a
conservative she is strongly
against the woke crowd. So we
respect her a lot for that she
fights them all the time and
she was on Bill Maher show.
Friday night real time. And she
went on a bit of a rant that
wind everywhere. She said
that she has had enough she is
over it. She
explained why and listen to the
audience reaction throughout
this this is a notoriously left
wing audience out there in La
for Bill Maher she had a lot of
the crowd behind her as she
said this in cut 14. I'm done.
>> With covid you know I've
done it, yeah I
I went so covid I remember raid
the Pringles cans that I bought
at the grocery store strip, my
clothes off because I thought
covid would be on my clothes.
>> Like I did it all I watched
Tiger King, I've got to the end
of spotify like.
>> Did it right.
Good know a lot of us to
do it and then we were told you
get the vaccine. You get the
vaccine and you get back to
normal. And. We haven't gotten
back to normal. And it's
ridiculous at this point.
I know that so many of my
liberal and progressive friends
are with me on this and they
do not want to say it out loud
because they are scared to be
called anti VAX or to be called
science denial or to be you
know smeared is a Trump or I'm
sorry if you believe the
science you will look at the
data that we did not have 2
years ago and you will fit find
out that cloth masks do not do
anything.
>> So she's clearly on a roll
here and she didn't stop there.
Barry Weiss continues cut 15.
>> You will realize that you
can show your vaccine passport
at a restaurant and still be
asymptomatic a crime and you
will realize most importantly
this is going to be remembered
by the younger generation as a
catastrophic moral crime.
The city of Flint Michigan
which is 80% I think minority
students has just announced
indefinite virtual schooling
in the past 2 years we've seen
among young girls a 51%
increase in self-harm
people are killing themselves.
They're anxious. They're
depressed they're lonely
that is why we need to end it
more than any inconvenience
that it's been to the rest of
us. I think.
It's a
pandemic of bureaucracy.
It's not let's not real
anymore.
>> It's a pandemic a
bureaucracy big crowd. We need
to ended I'm over it. She said.
What's the phrase into my veins
directly into my veins. That's
how I felt watching that from
Barry Weiss and she speaks for
so many people. So many people
who did everything they were
told. And then it never seems
to quite end. And these
neurotic people. Keep
pretending that the data isn't
the data and there.
Made up version of science is
the real science, there are
still far too many of them
calling the shots.
Clip went around the world.
And got a lot of attention a
lot of applause, but some
people are not happy about
including Jimmy a cost over at
CNN who got demoted into a
weekend show. And how many
watch CNN on the weekends.
But he's got that show and all
he was not not pleased at all
with Barry Weiss how can she
say that take it away Jim cut
16.
>> I'm done with that attitude
honestly I mean you know, I
mean she's understand trolling
people to own the lives is not
a sacrifice.
>> She is a live Jim.
Jim Acosta course, a
progressive activists. With a
press badge. I'm
done with that attitude all how
brave of you.
So brave. Jim Acosta here's the
thing Jimmy. If you
don't like.
What Barry Weiss added you feel
like everyone should be an 8
masks and they should be
required just to
go out and live their lives to
have like every booster shot
from now until eternity you
Gemini can live your life that
way. You don't I guarantee
you don't by the way.
But you could if that's what
you want for you and your
family go for it. Knock
yourself out don't force that
on everyone else.
I'm so pro vaccine, everyone
who listens to the show knows
it I got double vaccinated and
I got covid it was pretty mild.
I will talk to my doctor next
month 6 months later, whether
it's time for a booster,
whether that makes sense for
me.
I knew address that with my
doctor, I'm leaning towards
doing it. I am
pro vaccine. I am also
John like Barry y says I've had
enough.
We'll talk about it later in
the show is just in Texas where
things were sensible and
normal. And you can make
decisions for yourself as an
adult. And then I flew to New
York which is where I am now
and it's like oh welcome back
to rules Ville even if the
rules make absolutely no sense.
>> So bill Maher on that same
show made a joke that made some
ladies on the view very They
were angry.
>> Here's are sad Friday night
on HBO cut 23.
>> And I want to live in your
paranoid world anymore your
mascara night world, you know
you go out it's silly now.
You know UW mass kept up a car
get the booster day scan your
head.
Like you're in cashier and I'm
a bunch of bananas.
>> I'm not good at is
you are.
>> So hoping Goldberg the view
who with all due respect knows
so little about
this stuff like some of her
comments in recent weeks shows
that
she knows.
>> So so little about the data
and the science but that does
not prevent her.
>> From waltzing into a studio
and talking to millions of
women every day.
And spreading a bunch of fear
and paranoia based on not data.
What a lot of self
righteousness she was big mad
at bill Maher for that joke cut
24. This was today.
That's.
>> Not really funny to people
have lost their kids to this
people lost family
members or do your friends to
this it's it's just you know
listen nobody on the planet
really wants to go through
this. This is not something
we're doing because it's you
know sexually gratifying this
is what we're doing to protect
our families and you don't have
to do it but stay away from
everybody because if you're the
one who's not
paying attention. And you
confidence needs you don't want
to end.
They don't stay out of the and
this is not nobody wants this
no I don't want it. This is the
fact that he's for getting the
people are still.
>> This is the thing Le pink.
>> If you want to
do all these things and want to
be super quote UNQUOTE safe
even though that's now at the
data shows that the science
you should be the one at this
point isolating yourself from
society don't force the rest of
us to live that way.
Forced the rest of us to live
that way and it is so cheap and
unfair to pretend that being
critical of
Dom
baseless nonsense restrictions
is somehow being cavalier and
callous towards the people who
have died of their families of
course not we give the number
every day on this show. People
who have died from this.
She talked about kids.
Tiny vanishingly small number
of cats far more kids have died
in car accidents and swimming
pool drownings then from covid
so to talk about kids again
that's just like another
example of fear mongering and
spreading garbage to try to
pull of people's heartstrings
and make them afraid.
Putting that stat into context
that's cruel. That's callous.
No it's not. It's about a
risk assessment, which is what
public policy as will be.
So she's all indignant.
Over Bill Maher saying we have
to get back
to something much closer to
normal and we cannot keep doing
these superstitious rituals
that don't align with the data
but what he was very angry
about that. And then one of her
co-hosts went on to say this in
cut 25.
>> They're over it like yeah,
him or to the post mascot port
part because I think there's a
prudent we've learned that the
mask, the hand Santa tape hand
sanitizing that kind of like
9.11 with flying is always
going to be here now there's a
new normal in the beginning
with a post 9.11 people don't
want to fly and the security
measures felt how do we do this
you know, and now it's the
norm. I think some of the
things we've learned in this
pandemic are going to stay the
same I mean ever write a subway
again without a mask, I mean
never go indoors to big crowds
never feel comfortable without
a mask and that's up to me to
do that.
>> That Sara Haines
again if that's what she wants
to do for the rest of her life.
She says it's prudent because
she's scared to wear a mask
everywhere she goes. Indoors in
crowds. Your call Sarah don't
impose that on everyone else
especially don't impose that on
children.
Where there are harms to
children for forcing them to
wear masks for hours every day
and there are not proven
benefits and it doesn't stop
the virus.
And kids by virtue of being
kids are basically vaccinated
against this disease because
almost none of them who
contract it get even moderate
let alone severe.
Let alone die.
The problem is they're having
that conversation on the view
and they all agree they're out
of step now at this point with
most of the country. And they
want to take their fears
and their so-called solutions
that are not based on science
and make that what we have to
do across the country in the
name of safety and Health.
And they want to do it
indefinitely. She said this
might become the new normal
know masking especially of
children can not become the new
normal this mentality, what you
just heard there from the
ladies at the view has to be
actively resisted and defeated.